back was there anything that you would
do differently and is there a different
advice that you would give to a 20 year
old girl that has the same opportunities
that you did
I think the biggest thing that I would
want to do differently is what were the
athletes
well I will say
um I have to be honest with myself
because I think it's easy to take the
cliche route and say like I would do
nothing differently now from the
wisdom I have acquired no I would not
change this wisdom for a clean slate and
that's just the god honest truth but I
will say to 20 year olds and even to my
20 year old self
I hate how I allowed myself to just be
like used up by men and that came from a
lack of self-worth I did not understand
my value that I was born with I didn't
and I gave
again people look at sex differently but
sex is spiritual unification at the end
I don't care how you spin it it's
spiritual women okay that's okay
whatever okay fine for women it's
spiritual unification
and people that I shared my body with
when I think about my list
it's repulsive
because they didn't deserve it
but that was an outcome of me
discounting my worth
and
it's disgusting
um
I hate even having that spiritual tie in
any type of way but yeah I would
absolutely change sexually how I move
around and not even necessarily because
of like the societal outcome it's more
so
from myself it makes you like feel yeah
it doesn't feel good
knowing that you gave a sacred part of
you to a man that looked at sex with you
as taking a piss
that's not fulfilling it's disgusting to
think about and I
feel like I've beat myself up every
single day for my decisions and what
people say about me online holds no
candle to what I've told myself on a
daily basis like there's I've been
called worse by better and that better
be me like I have talked down to myself
and I felt like I was unworthy for a
very long time and I would say this is
more of a recent awareness like for the
past year
um
where I'm like
Britney you were always enough like you
never had to seek validation outside of
you you never had to look that far and
um that's what I would would tell myself
I would and try to tell women
you should really think about who you're
laying down with like and that's that is
a more traditional view but it's like
sex is not even worth it if they don't
give a [ __ ] about you they don't care
about you they have no desire to they
don't want to know your favorite color
they don't give a [ __ ] so why do you
want them over top of you again that's
come from
feeling used up and sometimes that's why
the used Goods comments they sting
because you know what
there are times I felt like that I feel
like the old toy or sorry the new toy
that now is unexciting and put away in a
box so
I just have to accept what I've done and
move forward with this awareness and
just know that okay
the guy that I that most likely that I'm
not looking for a husband I'm looking
for my husband and there's a difference
that guy is going to be a very small
percentage and I'm okay with that I'm at
peace and I'm at peace with the things
I've done but I will say moving for like
talking to any girl to you and you know
whoever is listening it's like you
really should think about
why you're doing what you're doing what
like really think about why am I
attracting that what part of me is
resonating with
a guy like that if you have all these
complaints about him what's resonating
with him really analyzing what you're
doing that's what I would suggest so why
don't because in my head like
why wouldn't you avoid this if you could
go back you wouldn't avoid the
situations because you I thought in the
beginning you said that like you
wouldn't change it because of the wisdom
you've acquired but to me it's like oh
my God if I if I knew what I know now
like I probably I probably would have
waited till I was married no I can I I
get that I understand that I think that
I have a very influential voice and I
have grown to be a voice for women who
have gone through what I've gone through
and experienced what I've experienced
and
although I again I can't speak for the
majority because my situation still
isn't even average right and I'm aware
of that but
my voice is important just like your
voice is important and that's why I
don't I would not want to change
anything because what again I don't know
what my this is a very tough spot to be
in right because you're figuring it out
you have people who are also trying to
figure it out and it's like I'm needed
in this space because I my voice guides
those women that you guys talk about
right so that's why I wouldn't change it
because there's a greater picture even
in my like I told you my last
relationship had the Bentley had the
house had the kid
and it wasn't enough okay so it may be a
small percentage of us women who feel
this way but those I feel like that's
the voice that I'm I represent oh no oh
no there's a large percentage okay okay
well I mean I mean I mean I don't know
they're predicting that 45 of women will
be single and childless by 2030. so much
so that big banks are investing in like
cat food wine like things that go with
like single women wow yeah okay so I
feel like my voice does matter navigate
through this so it's like
uh it's like again it's such a small
percentage of men that you're like
looking for now I know yeah
um how do you want to navigate that like
moving forward
um do you give me do you even want a
date like right now because you you um
so I know some people when their kids
are young like just don't want to date
how do you like feel about that
um I think it has more to do with
where I'm at
um emotionally and
it's not even like a jaded thing right
it's more of
I know my value
I can talk to I can have one
conversation with a guy now
and I know exactly what he's about
so most of the guys that have presented
themselves in front of me just want to
[ __ ] me
I'm not interested in that
and I'm going to keep my I'm going to
keep an open mind and I'm going to keep
an open heart but I know by how a man
approaches me how he speaks to me I know
that there's that that he wants more
with me it is just I know so that's
where I'm like I'm not going on dates
right now I'm not talking I don't have
somebody that we talk every few days
every day
I have no masculine energy besides like
my family our family friend Jerry
um have no masculine energy
in my in my in my sphere in my bubble I
don't because I think
I focused on men and just dick in
general for a very long time
and now I'm I'm just gonna get to the
business
um I understand that the window the
percentage it's it's it's changed a lot
from when I was 22. so all I can do is
kind of equip myself financially take
advantage of the opportunities I have
now to set myself up because I can't
rely on
a man and come someone coming to save me
I can only save myself now so that's why
I'm dating is not a focal point but I'm
not like turning guys away that that
actually want to get to know me like as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible